cnn has changed his tune abruptly cnn
has decided that the rioting kenosha
needs to stop because
it might be hurting joe biden's chances
of winning he's got to come out and tell
people
that he is going to deal with the issue
of police reform
in this country and that what's
happening now is happening under donald
trump's
watch the rioting has to stop
chris as you know and i know it's
showing up in the polling
it's showing up in focus groups it is
the only
thing it is the only thing right now
that is sticking
it's showing up in the focus groups
quote therefore it matters
victor davis hansen is a senior fellow
at the hoover institute happy to have
him on tonight professor have you ever
heard anything more cynical than that
we need to stop killing people because
it's showing up in the focus groups
very rarely i think they thought joe
biden was going to run out the clock he
had an eight or nine point lead in the
polls he was going to be in the basement
everybody was told to allow things to
continue as they were and donald trump
owned them as the incumbent president
and then they made a really devil's
bargain with the sanders people these
are the shock troops
in the street of bernie sanders and they
were basically saying to biden
we'll provide the anarchy and the chaos
you can then
uh accept our agenda after the election
when you win
we get our agenda through with you and
then you can promise the country the
violence ends and it probably wouldn't
so
joe biden is a prisoner of these people
i'm not sure he could renege on the
bargain if he wanted to and finally
if you're in a basement and you're not
looking at america your news comes from
abc
cbs c nbc cnn you know pbs npr
washington
uh post and you're not really seeing
where the country is
the country's going one way and the
media is saying george floyd
uh defund the police going the other and
biden is in complete echo chamber it's
sort of like
hillary thinking she's going to get a
landmark
landslide mandate by going into georgia
and arizona in the eve election and
blowing
blowing the election and having her blue
wall crumble he doesn't have the
information because he's isolated
and i think now the polls are finally
seeping into these people
he said oh my god the country is sick of
this stuff
and the polls are going and trump's
creeping up in the zombie poll or these
other
uh focus groups and we've got to do
something quick but it's not based on
principle
they mortgaged their souls a long time
ago to create this chaos and they said
to america
we'll stop it if you elect us yep and
that's where we are